to help you get a better sense of our  characters in marvel studios eternals  we're going to play a little game called  choose your eternal  i'm still going to win there are no  winners in shoes your eternal what are  you talking about  which eternal is most likely to leave a  party early cersei athena druid druid  because he is moping all the time it's  most likely to make you laugh in the  middle of a battle gilgamesh  sprite because she doesn't take anything  seriously oh  i'm a big baby  always be on time not cersei what did i  miss is that even a question makari  makari because she bends time dominate  at karaoke night fast ass kingo uh  me  challenge star-lord to a dance-off uh  ajak aja ajak she's not to be overlooked  when it comes to the boogie be the life  of the party  kingo kingo gilgamesh cut why don't you  think about it and we'll get back to you  lead the avengers truth ajax fastest i'd  like to think then i could lead them  [Music]